so I actually still have my ticket for
this film 10-year old ticket I'm going
to save that it might be worth something
someday probably not but it might maybe
the two towers was the first one that I
experienced in theaters as I said in my
original review fellowship came along on
DVD 2 blew me away and so by the time
this one came out in theaters I was set
I was on board I was ready to experience
this and I was pumped for this movie too
Towers is a film that is a little bit
different from the first in a certain
way for one you have all the characters
now in place and so you can now move
forward and it starts just right off the
bat you have to have seen the first film
you can't just come into this one you
have to watch these films in order but
it's different in the sense that it does
have a slightly more sombre feel to it
the first one was a little more hopeful
it was a little more adventure filled
and as the first one ended with the
death of Gandalf and everything it
turned the series into a more darker
direction the whole series really has a
dark tone to it really but this one just
had a slightly more meditative feel you
know it's a little bit slower it's the
one with the least action out of all
three of them yes the Battle of Helm's
Deep at the end is just non-stop and
sanity of Awesomeness but for the most
part the first two acts of this movie
don't have as much action as the first
film did or as Return of the King does
there's a lot more character development
a lot more building of these
relationships you get introduced to new
characters King Theoden which is one of
the most important characters in the
entire trilogy he's a character that you
didn't learn about in the first film you
don't hear about him he didn't meet him
he's one of the biggest pieces of the
two towers his character and Bernard
Hill plays him very well I was really
impressed with this performance I
actually kind of feel like it's an
oscar-worthy performance in itself you
get introduced to this character and he
is just nothing he's just a brick wall
Karl Urban and his his son this guy
doesn't care at all about what's
happening in Rohan he doesn't care about
his people anymore and he's basically
controlled by this guy Grima Wormtongue
this little disgusting man that for some
reason reminds me of Chris Kattan from
SNL I don't know why what he does but
he's being controlled by Saruman who's
being controlled by Sauron all these
people are being controlled to do evil
things and there's this amazing scene
where Gandalf comes in because yes
Gandalf the white comes back in this
movie very early
he comes in and he's just walking
straight forward to this King is you
will not get out of here all the Sonora
and the greatest thing about the scene
is there's all this epic action
happening around him like Aragorn and
Gimli and Legolas are taking out these
guys but you don't see that you just see
him kind of blur through the background
the camera stays with Gandalf because
that's where the focus of the scene is
Peter Jackson didn't allow himself to
let's just show the action over here
while Gandalf says some words he made it
so much more epic by focusing on Gandalf
while having these guys running around
the background it looked so great it was
such a cool way for him to do this scene
so once Gandalf throws Saruman out of
the Kings body basically this guy is
able to then realize where his country
has come through that Aragorn is able to
create a relationship with him and these
people in which he kind of starts to
feel like maybe I could be a king you
get that sense where he's just such a
good leader where he can lead these
people throughout this battle and you
really feel that in this movie now
perhaps the most important piece of this
movie in regards to everything is riding
on this one character otherwise the
movie will fail is Gollum portrayed by
Andy Serkis brilliantly thank goodness
this didn't turn out to be a Jar Jar
Binks thing because this thing could
really come off pretty horrific aliy
annoying and there are a few scenes
really okay we get it he likes the fish
and everything what could he do but it's
nothing really it's just such an amazing
feat this character and even watching
the film you know it's ten years old now
it still is mind-blowing the work that
was done motion capture work and by this
actor just the performance that he gave
it's great and all the different
technical things that went into that
character were so impressive it's kind
of like the Yoda of Empire Strikes Back
without that character if it hadn't
worked if it hadn't been convincing the
movie would have been brought down
seriously on a lot of levels now Frodo
and Sam have split off from the group in
this movie and they're going of course
to Mordor to throw the ring into the
mountain the thing that you start to see
in this movie really is it starting to
eat away at Frodo you start to see it
that the toll that it's taking on him
physically emotionally and mentally you
really start to feel that in this movie
and that's one of the things that was
portrayed so well in all three of these
movies is the alluring quality of the
ring
what it is capable of doing you really
start to think of this inanimate object
as if it is a living being or entity of
some kind that has thoughts and wills
and desires it goes really well saying
that this movie looks incredible I mean
the cinematography in these movies is
beautiful it just makes you want to go
to all these places you just want to go
to New Zealand and stand on a mound and
just feel like wow this stuff is on this
earth like it's just everything in this
movie looks so amazing and that's when
the great things about this series too
is because although there's a lot of CGI
work in it Peter Jackson has a good way
of incorporating CGI with realistic
things and putting something CGI or you
know not real in a mostly real shot
that's where a lot of the CGI really
works in these movies it's because it's
incorporated with something that
actually exists most of the scenery and
everything in the backgrounds and
everything is real they really are in
these amazing places in New Zealand and
that really helps these movies tell the
story as well there's a great emotional
undercurrent in this movie with Aragorn
and Miranda Otto's character who starts
to kind of have a crush on him even
though it definitely added depth to that
relationship I felt like wow woman
you've only known him for like a day
maybe don't fall in love with people in
a day cuz you know that's not a good
idea but hey whatever I like that
character though because she's a strong
woman you know she's strong and
physically maybe not so much emotionally
because she met a man with a beard and
long hair and was like oh he's so hot
let's say let's be married now oh you
who gave you that necklace that was a
woman oh okay yeah well whatever when we
turn the king I look over at Boromir for
one second and it'll all be okay because
I'll find my man then no but seriously
the two towers is a film that builds and
builds and builds and you can feel like
this sense of urgency and I don't really
want to say that a lot of its exposition
I'm going to say that it's building to
something and that's the Battle of
Helm's Deep one of the best battle
sequences ever put to film it is
mind-blowing the amount of work that was
put into that movie if you watch the
special features on the blu-rays where
do you even begin I mean as a filmmaker
to approach something like that what do
you do you do it's like it I would
explode I don't know I would be so
excited to film it but it's like wow the
stuff that went into that sequence and
the amount
suspense they were able to sustain you
know with the ORAC I army coming up and
they're hitting their spears against the
ground and Aragorn commanding all the
elves and the humans and everything and
they added a great sense of comedy to
with Gimli and Legolas counting how many
people they were able to kill it with a
story of Gollum and Frodo and Sam and
the deception that's going on there and
how he's splitting Sam and Frodo apart
it really gave that relationship more
emotion and although I do like
fellowship a tad more possibly because
it just you know it is the slowest of
the three I feel because it has the
least amount of spread out action of the
three but I don't really feel like I can
fault the film for that I think the only
thing about the movie that I wasn't a
huge fan of was the Treebeard stuff I
don't really care for him as a character
and I've never really been a Marion
Pippen fan I know that this is really
the film where Mary kind of starts to
mature more Pippin still a little boy in
this film really Return of the King is
where Pippin gets spanked and he starts
to actually go like oh okay there's
actually some huge life-altering war
around me I better step up to the plate
so that story element didn't interest me
as much as the others but you know I'm
not really gonna fault the film for that
because these three films are like one
gigantic movie and all these pieces have
to be in there for the film's to work to
towers' is an excellent film with an
amazing scope beautiful music once again
great performances incredible battle
sequences it for sure gets an A+ so guys
I just wanna let you know this is
probably going to be the last video I
film in this apartment I have rented a
new place for myself I'm going to be
moving in tomorrow so please bear with
me as I assemble my new poster
background it might look a little crappy
for a week or two but I'm going to be
moving in there tomorrow and so this is
actually going to be my last video here
I'm going to try to make it look similar
recreated as best I can but thanks a lot
for sticking with me as always and if
you liked this review then you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes